[Musique]
sabine weiss dans ses oeuvres est
désormais de l'autre côté de l'objectif
de vent à son tour celui des
photographes pendant 75 ans sabine weiss
a parcouru le monde sait appareil en
bandoulière pour photographier la vie
plutôt immortaliser des instants de vie
guidée par cette nécessité de sauver ce
qui va disparaître
le premier appareil j'avais 13 ans et
j'ai rien fait beau avec j'ai
photographié vasseur ma mère m'en ma
tortue mais pour par contre je le
prenais ça très au sérieux puisque gmail
et coller ces deux photos ce dans un
album et il ya marqué en eau
mon premier film et la date
et c'est drôle que j'aï cogérant que
j'ai dit c'est mon premier film c'était
vraiment le jeu ne savais pas que j'en
aurai pas mal de doutes par la suite de
ses multiples films et pellicules 200
photographies ont été sélectionnés pour
un hommage exceptionnel sur trois lieux
et trois expositions simultanées
michel dubois en a été l'un des artisans
lui qui place la photographe aux côtés
des cartier bresson et douaniers
sabine est une personne extrêmement
attachante et effectivement mon grand
regret c'est qu'elle n'est pas
suffisamment connue du grand public elle
mérite elle mérite mieux
je veux dire elle a fait l'objet de très
grande exposition est là il a fait
l'objet de très grandes publications à
la parcouru le monde entier
mais c'est vrai que le grand public ne
l'a ne la connais pas
on
inconnu célébrités noir et blanc ici à
l'autre bout du monde
ombres et lumières floues et net une
constante cependant humain avec une
prédilection pour les photos d'enfants
c'est bien les enfants ça bouge c'est
naturel on peut les mettre au défi de
faire quelque chose dans quelques fois
mais ça c'est rare et c'est c'est que
qu'avec des certaines photos d'enfants
il ya des photos la plupart sont
vraiment prise à l'improviste très très
rapidement
à
à fait
à 90 ans passés dont plus des deux tiers
appareil photo à la main partout dans le
monde
sabine weiss a définitivement rangé ses
boîtiers et ses objectifs
[Musique]